yeah what's your craziest interaction
with a fan oh I got my signal stage I'm
sorry what kind of were you facing
the stage of facing away and kind of
moving to the music I was still
performing you're still laughing while
you're getting your doctor sick give me
a moment Jerry give me an O good guy
why'd you can't have I had as a homie
the coolest person okay now listen what
is your relationship with marijuana oh
we go way back
yeah you do I guess I started back about
13 maybe you know the first time I
tasted it I was like oh my god where
we've been on my life where you been for
13 years yeah exactly
so Jerry what's the weirdest thing
you've ever smoked weed out of no I
think I was in jail with the Apple yeah
how did you get marijuana into a jail I
don't know I'm pretty sure it came doing
somebody bullied oh hey look when you're
in jail
you got a smoke that booty we're here
after we go to trouble a ticket we have
their booty for you you gotta serve it
rude not to